If you can stop where you are right now
and ask yourself the question, do I have
a conversation coming up that I am
stressed about, worried about, that's
weighing on me? If that's you, then this
is your episode. I'm going to walk you
through it. We're going to talk all
about how to prepare for hard
conversations, the stressful
conversations, the ones that put that
knot in your stomach as soon as you
start thinking about it. I got you. By
the end of this episode, you're going to
feel a million times better. You ready?
Let's go. Welcome to the Jefferson
Fisher Podcast, where I'm on a mission
to make your next conversation the
[music] one that changes everything.
Wherever you are listening, if you would
please press subscribe or heart or
[music] like or leave a comment, it
helps me more than you know. And in
exchange, my [music] promise is to you
to make you a better communicator. If
you subscribe and you listen to these
episodes, [music] it's going to make you
a better communicator. and in exchange,
you're going to have much better
relationships and a better life, and
that's a very positive thing. Thank you
so much. This episode is brought to you
by Cozy Earth. I love Cozy Earth because
the products they make are topnotch
everything. In fact, their whole website
is stuff that I scroll through and I'm
like, "Oo, I want this. Oo, I want
that." That's the kind of website it is.
So, I encourage you to go check it out.
What do they make? Anything that's cozy
is the best way to put it. Anything that
feels good that it's from bed sheets to
bath towels to bath sheets to the pants
that I'm wearing right now. Everything
that is cozy. So, if you're like me and
you're going into these holidays and
it's all of a sudden, man, your house is
a whole lot colder. It's I don't really
want to put on jeans to look nice when
I'm heading to the grocery store. I want
some stretchy pants. Cozyear is where
you need to be looking. Go to
cozyearth.com/jfferson.
Use the code Jefferson for up to 40%
off. That's cozyearth.com/jfferson.
and use the code Jefferson for up to 40%
off. And now, let's get into the
episode. So many times I have people
that are reaching out to me and saying,
"Hey, I am preparing for this
conversation that I have at work at the
office. I have this interview. I need to
fire an employee. I need to try and ask
for a raise. I have to have this hard
conversation with my spouse or my child
or or whatever it is." And every time
deep down, it's a plea for help of
knowing I am afraid. That's that's what
I hear. It's it's fear. It's fear from
everyone saying, "I I'm nervous about
this." News flash, I get nervous about
conversations, too. If you're not
getting nervous, let me just put that
disclaimer out there. If you're not
feeling nervous about a conversation,
then you don't care about the
conversation. So, I want you to
understand that when you feel nervous
and you're going, "Why do I why I have
this pit in my stomach?" Take that as
joy. Count it as joy that you actually
care about what you're going to say. You
care about the person. You care about
that conversation. If you didn't care,
you wouldn't really worry at all about
your words. you wouldn't worry about
their interaction or the reaction from
them. So understand when you have that
nervous pit in your in your stomach
there, we're going to use that as good.
All right? We're going to use that as
good. And we're going to talk about that
in this episode. So, how do you best
prepare for this conversation? And I say
this conversation because I'm talking to
you. We're talking about the very
conversation you know that you need to
be having that is weighing on you, that
you are avoiding, that every time you
think about it, it keeps you up at
night. it you you lose track of what
you're doing. All of a sudden, your your
thoughts go out of focus because you're
so worried about this conversation. This
is the conversation we're going to be
talking about. Here's how I want you to
start preparing for it. You ready?
Number one, name your goal before your
emotions do. Set your goal for what you
want the conversation to be and how you
want it to turn out before your emotions
do. If you go into a conversation and
you don't have a goal, you are losing.
And I don't say that in terms of a
win-loss type of situation. I'm saying
you are setting yourself up for failure
if you don't have a goal. That is like
me saying, "Hey, you want to jump in the
car with me real quick?" And you go,
"Okay, where are we going?" I'm like, "I
have no clue. No idea, but I'm going to
spend 45 minutes of us just kind of
wandering around until I decide where I
might want to park." You go, you're
you're crazy. If I if I want to go on a
flight and you said, 'Where you going?'
I go, I you know, I don't really know.
It wouldn't make sense. You need to have
a destination. You have to have a
destination for what is the end result.
So, you start backwards. How do you
prepare for a difficult stressful
conversation? You start at the very end
of it. All right? You start at the very
end. What do I want them to know? So, if
you have if you can right now, I want
you to get a piece of paper out, maybe a
a word document, a Google document,
whatever it is, and I want you to write
down goal and then put a colon. What is
my goal for this conversation? If you
don't know the goal, you're lost. You're
lost because the other person is going
to be looking to you of where are we
going? What what is what do you want?
Ever had anybody say, "What's your
point? Where are you going with this?
That's exactly what it is because you're
not telling them, you're not informing
them of your destination. And that
leaves both of you absolutely clueless.
When you write down your goal, meaning I
want them to hear me, I want them to
understand me. I want them to do this or
I need to feel this.
It's going to help clarify what your
standard is. If your goal is for them to
change their mind, that's going to be
very difficult. If your goal is for them
to apologize to you, n that's probably
the wrong goal. It is has to be some the
goal has to be something that you can
control. You can't control if they're
going to apologize or say that you're
right or that everything they believe in
is wrong. You have to set a goal that
you can control. That has to do with you
understanding what's happening. You
feeling more like you have a better
solid footing in the conversation. You
getting to say the thing that you've
always wanted to say. You see, these are
words that are coming from you, not what
you're expecting them to say. Having a
goal is so critical. It sounds basic.
It is basic. It is extremely difficult
to have the right goal. What happens a
lot of the time is
you have something in your head about
how the conversation should go and then
you get into the conversation and you
realize, wait, this isn't happening.
Have you ever been into a conversation
and you realize, well, wait, wait, no,
no. This isn't how it's supposed to
happen. That you're you were I was going
to say this and then you were supposed
to apologize because that's that's how I
rehearsed it in my head. This is where
you say how wrong you are. How how you
finally are seeing the light. That's
never going to happen.
If it does, congratulations. Go get a
lottery ticket because that's going to
be extremely rare. Conversations rarely
go how they go in your head. That's just
not the way the world works. So, you
need to write down your goal. What do
you want from them? What do you want for
you?
Basic goal. A very basic goal. Maybe
it's I want to feel heard on this issue.
I need to understand where they're
coming from.
I need to let them go from the company.
I need to inform them that this is their
last day. Whatever it is, you need to
have a goal and make that the bright
line header of your true north. Without
it, you might as well not have the
conversation at all. You with me? Number
two, put the emphasis on regulating your
body more than rehearsing your words. In
fact, I would go on to tell you that
rehearsing your lines
is damaging. Let me tell you why. I see
so many times in the legal field, and
there's a lot of attorneys, trial
attorneys who might be listening right
now nodding their head. Good attorneys
don't stick to line by line questions.
They keep it flexible. So, what does
that look like? Let's say I have a pen
and paper. All right? Rather than
writing and scripting out every single
one of my questions that I want to ask a
witness, instead I'm going to put it in
bullet points. I'm might the first
bullet point might be the store. It
might be um the money exchange. It might
be
um the trip. Like things that are
signposts to me that allow me to ask
questions and be flexible. Because let
me tell you the downside of rehearsing
and knowing my questions ahead of time
is that I might read a question and wait
for the answer
except I typically don't wait for the
answer. I'm starting to look at the next
question and I'm worried about what I'm
going to ask more than I'm actually
listening. So you know a new attorney a
green attorney from a more veteran by if
they're going and did you arrive at the
school that day and they're not even
really listening to the answer. Somebody
could be giving a very good answer
that's giving them lots of information,
but they're not listening because
they're just focused on the next
question. So, you miss things. That's
the point. You miss things. If you are
rehearsing your lines, you're going to
miss things because you're more focused
on you performing well, of you doing
well. Oh, no, no, that's not how I
wanted to say it. People who teach
public speaking,
if you rehearse your talk, you're going
to be much more concerned about the
exact wording and putting your placement
and making almost so manufactured that
it doesn't feel genuine and it doesn't
feel real and the other person's not
going to feel it versus you just know
generally where the message needs to be.
You know your goal, you know your
purpose and why you're there. and that
you're going to trust everything's going
to flow out of that and that's where you
feel the connection from people. So, put
the emphasis on regulating your body.
Then we can worry about is is there a
certain type of phrase that you want to
make sure and use because if you don't
have your body controlled, if you are
not
using your breath and you are not
lowering your shoulders and you are
making sure your jaws not is your jaw
tight right now, are do you have
tightness in your ears and in your
cheeks and your forehead? And
what about your shoulders [snorts] and
your hands? Are they they tense?
Is your is your core tight? Are are you
your shoulders drooped over? What's your
body position like? So, you have to make
sure you take temperature of that. If
you don't have your body controlled,
good luck trying to focus everything
else because your body's tied to those
emotions. And if you're not breathing,
it doesn't matter what kind of technique
I could teach you, what words I could
give you, none of it's going to work
because it's going to come out in a way
that you don't want. It's going to come
out defensive because your body is
feeling defensive because your body is
feeling flooded in that moment. So
control you can control. How do I want
you to prepare for this hard
conversation? Regulate your body. Put
the focus on that. Before we keep going,
I want to take a second to tell you
about gusto. Now, many of you, like
myself, are business owners. I have a
law firm. I have this media side of uh
the podcasting. I I've owned a
restaurant, a coffee shop. I've done all
kinds of things. And let me tell you one
thing that is not fun as a business
owner that is extremely stressful and
that is payroll because you want I know
especially small business businesses you
want to take care of your people. You
want to not only offer a a great wage
you want to make sure that paperwork is
smooth, taxes are difficult. Like for
anybody who's never owned a business you
go, how do I pay people? Gusto all right
is been my saving grace long before they
sponsored this podcast right now. All
right. I' I've used them for probably
seven years. Gusto is an online payroll
and benefits software built for small
businesses. It's all-in-one. It's remote
friendly and incredibly easy to use. So,
you can pay, hire, onboard, and support
your team from anywhere. It has been
such
a help to me in the way that it makes it
easy to onboard people. It takes care of
taxes for and especially if you have
people that are remote and working in
other states. It will sign all that
stuff up for you for each state entity.
Keep it all in one dashboard. You can
have as many pay unlimited payroll runs
for one monthly price. And it's it
[snorts] really is easy. So you can go
try Gusto today at gusto.com/jfferson
and get three months free when you run
your first payroll. That's three months
of free payroll at gusto.com/jfferson.
One more time, gusto.com/jfferson.
I can promise you I've used them for so
many years and I have currently right
now I have four businesses that do
payroll through them and I would not
look at anybody else go to gusto. All
right, now back to the episode preparing
for this conversation. I want you to
think in your mind think in your mind
what are Imagine the conversation
happening in real time. The person
sitting across from you. You're at the
you're in the environment that you're
going to have the conversation with. How
does that feel? How does that feel to
you? What emotions are coming up?
Prepare for them now. Prepare for them
now. So, underneath wherever you're
writing, underneath goal,
I want you to write my responses. I'm
not talking about words. I'm talking
about your physical body responses.
What's going to be happening to you in
that moment? You need to know. Do you
get tightness in your jaw? For me, it's
tightness in my shoulders right here.
The traps. I get I get really tight when
I when I know I'm tense because I have
to like constantly relax them. It's my
body preparing. I have to constantly
react. I have to constantly relax them.
So in my response is say what's
happening to you. Jog it's tight. Fist
clench.
Shoulders tense.
I had somebody who say my toes my toes
like to uh scrunch up. If you need if
that's you write that down too. You need
to know what's happening. Why? so that
you will not be surprised when it's
happening. It's preparing for every part
of the conversation. Conversations are
not just words. They are the emotions
and the physical elements in the room.
All right? It is it is not just emotion.
It is just as physical as can be because
they're going to read your body language
more than they're going to listen to
your words. So, when it comes to
preparing for this hard conversation,
focus on regulating your body first
before we start worrying about your
words. Cool. Number three, while we're
talking about words, if you're going to
rehearse anything, I want you to
rehearse your opening line. That's it.
Know your opening line. That's it.
Whenever you start to think of [snorts]
how it's going to play out five minutes
into the conversation, there's no way
that's going to happen.
If you can get out your opening line
really well, that's really the only
thing you can control at the init at the
start of the conversation. Everything
else is going to be what it's going to
be and it's all going to be on you and
your emotions. Now, I say start with
your opening line because that sets the
tone for the conversation. That in to my
in my opinion is absolutely worth
rehearsing that you feel really
comfortable with the first words that
come out of your mouth. I'd say that 98%
of the time the direction of the
conversation is set by the tone and in
the first words that you share. So if I
want to have a hard conversation with
you, I'm going to put a lot of emphasis
in my mind of remembering rehearsing my
the opening what I want to begin with.
So I want you to write down underneath
my responses my opening my opening.
Write down your opening sentence to this
person. Imagine yourself in the context
and get really comfortable with the
opening sentence. What I like to open
with, and I'm just gonna I'm gonna throw
out some responses that that might feel
natural to you. All right? Is saying,
"I'm going to share something that's
really important to me. I like to to
share something that's very important to
me." Something as simple as that.
if you want to add to it. I want to
share something that's really important
to me and
I know it's not going to be perfect
or you can even ask and is it okay with
you if I if I don't say everything
perfectly.
This is going to be a difficult
conversation but I'm going to be right
here with you through the end.
This is a conversation that I know it's
not going to be resolved now
and I'm going to be in this conversation
over the next month for however long it
takes.
Sometimes put not putting a time frame
on conversation is very helpful. Instead
of saying we need to have a conversation
right now and expect a decision, this is
a conversation we're going to have over
the next week, over the next month,
whatever it is. When you release the
time, it's like the pressure valve goes
off. You're releasing the pressure, the
tense moment of it. Find your opening
line.
Maybe it's you needing to reveal some
stuff like, "I'm struggling with some
thoughts and I really want your help.
I'm stressed about this conversation
because it matters so much to me." I'd
encourage you to actually reveal a
little bit about what's happening
inside. Reveal the nerves. Reveal the
imperfect. Reveal the struggle. Believe
it or not, it's going to help them
relate to you more than you could ever
dream. If you sit with them and say,
"This is a conversation I've been
dreading to have,
and I hope that together
we can get through this in a way that's
going to make a big difference." This is
a conversation I've been dreading to
have, and I I really need your help.
There's something I I want to share with
you, and I I know I'm I'm not going to
get it down perfectly.
Are you willing to just be here with me?
Be willing to
reveal a little bit. Just I'm not saying
a lot, but if your opening line can be
just a little bit vulnerable with the
inner emotions,
what that's going to do is break so much
ice to actually be real to talk to one
another. All right. How do we prepare
for that difficult conversation, that
stressful conversation? Instead of that
knot in your stomach, we're going to
move some energy. You do that by writing
down what we just talked about. So,
number one, know your goal. Number two,
know your responses, your body, what's
happening. That way, you're not going to
get caught off by it in the moment. And
number three, rehearse your opening
line. Know your opening line because
that you can at least control. And
additional bonus if you can reveal a
little bit of the struggle. What are you
struggling with yourself? [snorts] Like
if you were just going to talk to me and
say, um, you Jefferson, I want to have
this hard conversation and I'm worried
about it because I'm I'm I'm afraid
they're not going to I'm afraid reveal
that whatever that is. I'm afraid that X
maybe you need to write that down too.
I'm afraid that
and use that fear and put it at the
beginning of the conversation. I need to
share something important with you and
I'm I'm afraid that if I do this is
going to happen. You hear how all of a
sudden you've got that out in the open.
You're not you're not you're not
carrying that inside. It's not unspoken.
You've now said it and now they can
understand. Okay, this is this is
serious and now I'm going to have this
conversation with you.
All right,
I'm proud of you. I want to encourage
you that this is not everybody does
this.
Let me tell you, nobody does it super
well. Even the conversations I need to
have. Yeah. Do I make mistakes? Yeah.
But that's what makes me human. There's
no such thing as a perfect stressful,
hard, difficult conversation gone well.
The best thing you can do is find
the reason within yourself. Why is it
difficult? When I say difficult
conversation, what makes it difficult?
Find that answer. Be more focused on
that answer. If you can just remove the
difficulty, then it's just a
conversation.
Then it's not a difficult one. It's just
a conversation. And sometimes what makes
it difficult is not the other person,
it's me. Do the homework, prepare for
it, plan for it, and you will not be
surprised. And when you eliminate the
surprises, you reduce the anxiety, and
all of a sudden, what you thought was so
difficult really just becomes another
conversation. All right, you got this.
If you can encourage, I want to not only
encourage you, but whenever you do have
that conversation, will you email me? I
you can go um hell@jffersonfisher.com.
I I would love to hear how that
conversation went and get any kind of
feedback because I just want to
encourage you and speak a lot of good
into your life. All right. As always,
you can try that and follow me.